كشفت معلومات جمعها موقع ان اكثر من 120
مدرسه ايرانيه تعرضت طالباتها لحاله تسمم
بمواد سامه امس الاثنين وابهرت المعلومات
ان هذه المدارس توزعت في 25 محافظه
ايرانيه منها كردستان وفارس وطهران
واصفهان وكرمان وزاره الصحه الايرانيه
بدورها اعلنت ان الماده المسببه لتسمم
ليست بالضروره ماده واحده يمكن لكشف عن
اسمها وشيره الى ان اقل من 10% من
التلميذات اللواتي تعرضنا للتسمم ظهرت
عليهن الاعراض وان البقيه قد يعانين من
الاعراض فقط لجعورهن بالقلق والتوتر دون
التعرض لسبب التهيج
هذا واتهم احد الطلاب في جامعه الاهواز
علي سعيد جليل ممثل المرشد الايراني في
المجلس الاعلى للامن القومي الايراني
والنظام بالعجز عن حمايه الاطفال في
المدارس من السموم التي تستهدفهم
اذا قلتم ان التسميم في المدارس ليس من
فعلكم بل وراءه الاجانب عفوا اذا انتم
فاشلون جدا لانكم لا تستطيعون ضمان سلامه
هؤلاء الاطفال